well my first thing is a question do we
have any business here and there so when
I teach I'd like to know whom I'm
teaching so if you don't mind just start
on this side and tell me what state
you're from you name it I'm not name but
just just everyone states you from
Georgia
hi Sanford just one at a time so I kind
of your front go back I know there's
something all go ahead that's New York
right okay I know there's some over
there
very good thank you okay Laura I know
there's some over how about in the
middle different ones Massachusetts no
rival Tennessee Arkansas Michigan Ohio
Hawaii Arizona Texas Mexico may go very
well its axis okay
you're very timid this volume will cook
a lot you thanks
Alaska okay well again Spain okay let's
find you by knowing I did know Panama
okay talking song
okay how about different ones on the far
side of thing
South Carolina Illinois Maryland your
ebony welcome Virginia where Vermont
come on dr. Rieux very good turn there
where George okay Danielle over the far
side I'm up behind me I can't place you
well yes sir I used to live that's very
any Californian and and in Hawaii I
lived at twice in Connecticut and I
lived in Virginia and Maryland I also
lived in northern New York State and
Schenectady New York
so all over the others behind me I did
okay do you have any pastors are
missionaries active or its house here
and it's this old stand up if you don't
mind give me your denomination and where
you serve glass yes ma'am
Presbyterian South Carolina that's what
my grandma's phone the others yes sir
I'll get I'll get that so all right
do you ever send this go vote
you have one of my Sunday school books
what guess you wanted to turn to the
right place I'd like for you to read
their scripture this morning for me when
the time comes she'll carry my Sunday
School yes
nondenominational and we're Brunswick
Georgia all right
your friends are friends of mine very
good oh yeah okay very good very good
okay wow you know how I wonderfully if
he was with my leader interested in
prayer this morning you might everybody
by his flesh
and diapers and other basic needs and
orphans will be taken care of as you
have charged us to do throughout the
Scriptures we ask for health for the
Carters and those others here and we ask
that we have open hearts here and bless
the learning that we will go out with we
thank you for the many who have offered
their time to come here today the
members of the church who worked so hard
in long hours in the long hours of the
night and as we go forward today please
give us new hearts to serve in your
world in your gracious name we pray amen
amen
thank you very much well I'd say we're
particularly honored this morning to
have the Congressional Black Caucus with
us all you stand up if you don't mind
okay we've had a lot of honest and this
year before Oh prime ministers have been
here presidents have been here president
candidates have been here this year and
we but this is a special on a special
honor I've ever had
Stanford thank you very much for having
organized I'm sure you did
well Rose and I have had some bad luck
lately without physical health we get
lonely otherwise I hope you won't see
otherwise when I try to teach their
lessons but we get along okay except for
physical health Rosen broke her hip
because of osteoporosis three weeks
before I did and she was in the hospital
I was with her at every University and
then also in Americus and then I broke
my hip three weeks ago
and I was waiting for Rosen to come pick
me up and I got a telephone call while I
was waiting I heard he had my bags
packed and he said Rosen has had a
stroke and she can't speak and I almost
fainted but it turned out there was a TI
a many of you know what idea is it's a
temporary suffering inability and so
after a few after 1/2 days in the
hospital we came home and we've been
home ever since we have nursing here
around the clock just to take care of us
and make us help us to move around our
own house so we get along fine now thank
you for your prayers and your and your
good wishes we have today and the rest
of this all of this month as a matter of
fact we're setting the Trinity and
particularly the Holy Spirit how many of
you have ever said it that before in
Sunday school
a few rays am strike assume many of you
have that's good we're going to
concentrate on the Holy Spirit and Jesus
Christ this week and and learn what we
can about it today also happens to be a
special day in a Christian Church
anybody know what idea it's a day of
Pentecost and what happened on Pentecost
Sunday first Pentecost when was it to
start with what's it where's the
Pentecost come from I can't hear you
fifty days after what after the birth of
Christ yes I'm sorry we have no festival
to celebrate and anyway oh well that
daily God's presence came and penetrated
the hearts of those assembled there and
that was the first time so the first
time fall and that's when we assumed it
was the birth of the Christian Church so
we're celebrating the birth of the
Christian Church and also celebrating
the anniversary of the of the first
Pentecost the what is what is the Holy
Spirit how would you describe it just in
your own terms
I'm sorry yes
pure love okay I'm sorry
Jesus here Jesus spirit I would say
God's Spirit because the Holy Spirit is
mentioned many times in the Old
Testament before the time of Christ and
several times in a New Testament the
Holy Spirit is mentioned before the
birth of Christ
when was the first time we know in the
New Testament that the Holy Spirit was
missions he buddy know it was it was
when the announcement was made to his
parents that John the Baptist would be
born and you know he said the Bible says
the Holy Spirit came upon John his wife
and and they said they were gonna have a
shuttle that were both very old and and
that his name would be John and they
gave a little information about him when
was the next time when the Holy Spirit
came he came to Mary so what was going
to happen
his friend she became pregnant with
Christ and she became pregnant through
what through the Holy Spirit he said the
Holy Spirit descended upon Mary and she
became pregnant with Christ in effect so
and then next time was after Jesus had
started his ministry and what what
occasion was that I'm sorry his baptism
John the Baptist was baptizing Jesus and
and the Holy Spirit came on him and he
said they descended like a dove and
Jesus saw the people around him saw the
Holy Spirit come so so it's really the
Holy Spirit isn't is a powerful presence
of God within inside Jesus the prophets
Moses David Sullivan and so forth and
also within the heart of Jesus Christ
and the apostles that's what we're going
to say about today and also who else all
of us right
okay so the Holy Spirit comes within our
hearts and that what matters what
motivates us develop the teachings of
Jesus Christ
and we always we might say inspired to
do something beyond and above the call
of duty or to serve others in a
particular way that is because of God's
presence within us it's not a it's not a
trick it's not a secret
oh it just describes accurately that
that's what it is but we need to be
reminded of it
in 2008 I met in my house three times
with two very distinguished Baptists one
was named Jimmy Allen and the other was
named Bill Underwood bill under what it
was then
there silly as a president of Mercer
University and we wanted to resurrect
you might say the Tri annual convention
of Baptists has anybody ever heard of
that before you have no well the
triangle convention beginning when the
Baptist Church came to America was held
try annually that means every three
years and he was held in Philadelphia
and all the Baptist representatives in
America would come to Philadelphia every
three years and celebrate their affinity
to one another and affinity to Jesus
Christ through the teachings of the
Baptist Church and and that lasted until
when
nobody knows that either
well this is turning into a issue that's
not but I don't mind that lasted until
1845 and when did that what happened
then there Southern Baptists decided
they did not want to meet anymore with
african-american Baptists so that's when
the Southern Baptist Convention was
found here so the Southern Baptist
Convention broke away from the Tri
annual convention and form their own
Southern Baptist Convention and it's
very now very strong and very powerful
well what Jimmy Allen and Bill Underwood
and I wanted to do was to resurrect the
trying him Commission so we worked hard
on it one of the main things was we
wanted to have it preferably you know in
a nice convenient place we chose special
Atlanta we considered other places as
well and and we held it in January of
2008 and we induced all of the African
American Baptist Convention's to change
their convention date and to move them
to Atlanta so you could imagine how long
that took to convince all of them to
change that they'd have a convention end
and to move it to it long so they are
great all four of the major ones agreed
to do it so we assembled in Atlanta to
the end of January in 2008 we had about
15,000 people come and more than half of
I'd say $8,000 more African Americans
and it was a wonderful glorious
completely successful inspirational
occasion
waiting view they are by any chance I'm
sorry to see that nobody was there well
I wasn't but we concentrated on on the
fact that all the Baptist's ought to be
in one place annually Oh as openers
needed so that we could share the belief
in Jesus Christ on an equal basis
regardless of racial just just
distinction so that's when the new
babies somebody started and you bet me
amazing so we brought them all together
and that's that's been going on ever
since not every every three years we
reassemble so if you want to know
whether samples this next year not you
can and increments of three to two
thousand eight so we had in 2011 2014 I
won't go down a whole list but uh but
it's been a wonderful occasion for us
and out of that has come a lot of very
difficult and challenging and successful
and inspirational efforts to bring
African American and white Baptists
together as complete equals I would say
like majority of their speakers at the
occasion will were well I'm Comerica I
was there and and Bill Clinton was there
among two of it well-known people we
enjoyed it very much so nowadays the new
Baptist Convention a commission I think
we call it
there's our
it's trying a different kind of thing
every every year and what we've done the
last few meetings as few you angel years
is to get the white churches all the
black churches it doesn't matter to to
assess the other churches in their own
community and reach out in some way and
invite the other congregations to come
over and and worship with them on an
equal basis we also have a very strong
prison ministry and and do other things
that we believe have a common problem or
a common challenge or common opportunity
so that's what that's what the new
better submission du BAP is covenant we
call it that's where it goes a lesson
today is John 14 15 to 20 and 26 and I'm
glad ximenos that for us I don't have a
microphone either
whom the world cannot receive because it
neither sees him you know him
in a little while the world will no
longer see me but you will see me
because on that day you will know that
my father and you and me they who have
my Commandments and keep them are those
who love me and those who love me will
be loved and I will love them and reveal
myself to them Judas not Iscariot said
to him Lord how is it that you reveal
yourself to us and not to the world
jesus answered him those who love me and
we will come to them whoever does not
love me does not keep my words and the
word that you hear is not mine but it's
from the father I have said these things
to you
thank you very much I wish I had a
lighter you didn't have a light did a
good job thank you well that happens
immediately after this was Jesus words
to his disciples right after he was
arrested and he had told him several
times before that that he was going to
be sentenced to death and executed and
he would be leaving them and so this
explains to his disciples and to us that
even though Jesus left Earth after he
was crucified and resurrected that he is
still with us through the Holy Spirit so
whenever we feel the presence of Jesus
in our heart that's all the spirit and
we know we know God in our hearts oh
that's the only spirit so it's an
easiest thing to explain but it's easy
to forget also so just remember that the
Holy Spirit is a powerful presence of
God or you might say Jesus in the hearts
of all of us it's a wonderful gift from
God
we arena this a month from John and I'd
like to point out one kind of
interesting thing in the book of John
when he describes the Last Supper
what is his description anybody know
that's right service Li he doesn't
mention Jesus body he doesn't mention
Jesus blood instead he describes vividly
how Jesus took off his clothes wrapped
himself in a towel and went around from
one disciple to another and watch that
feat and that's the first vivid
description of foot washing and imagine
how many I mean have you ever watched
anybody else's feet in church right not
in church you just do it outside of
church like your grandmother's feet all
right well it's not an easy thing to do
I'd say it's the most kind of physically
disabling thing that you can do wouldn't
you say
because you put yourself not only
physically at their feet but also you
acknowledge them as a superior person
and John through Jesus is emphasizing
for the disciples then and then later
for all of us he says do this in memory
of me just like he does for the Lord's
Supper
and he and he emphasized the fact that
we should do this to other people and
these spiritually or figuratively if we
don't do it in
we should be looked upon as servant
leaders I would say all the members of
Congress particularly these days are
servant leaders and all of us need to be
seven leaders let me ask you a question
I want all of you just for a moment to
imagine God's kingdom if it were fully
implemented on earth just imagine how
life would be if every aspect of Jesus
teaching was implemented on earth how do
you feel life would be changed no will
poverty all right no violence no piers
no fears no fears that's right
I'm sorry a lot more a lot more love
complete equality I would say yes clean
God's and Brahma would be careful right
we would be real stewards of the earth
joyful no more hunger right well would
you say back down
paradise paradise that's a good overall
description the kind of ends my
dissertation yeah what compassion for
everybody you see it's a little bit hard
to conceive is it not
but every every night I maybe some of
you pray that God's kingdom will come on
earth as it is in heaven and that's what
we can see and that is not an
impossibility
I was saying one of the main differences
would be to honor the Prince of Peace we
would have peace and a few weeks ago I
got my first call from President Ron I
was delighted and I was surprised first
time he'd ever called me and I had
written him a letter about the
relationships with China I normalize
diplomatic relations with China at the
beginning of the January 1940 1979 and
you know and I had my biggest problem
with the Japanese because when I was
president in ancient times the the big
problem that I had was with the Japanese
economically because it seemed like all
of the industry in America was moving to
Japan still aluminum automobiles
television radios shirts shoes because
labor was so low in Japan and we had a
constant series of arguments it bubbled
up to me and the Prime Minister of Japan
that time was mr. foo khuda and so funny
kukuda and i got together on one of my
trips to tokyo and we decided that we
would select three people from the
United States and three people from
Japan who were experts on the other
country either former ambassadors or
professors who had spent my life
studying the other country or something
like that and those six people we never
issued then
publicly we just chose them privately to
do that with understanding it they
didn't think that they would meet every
bravely whenever we had a problem to
come up and either fuku toe or I would
would transmit the problem through the
six-week whom we call Wiseman all of
them have to be men at that time and and
they would assess it one year they were
meeting took you over the next year they
would meet in Washington and in this
meeting and more often they were made in
Hawaii halfway so they spent a lot of
time in Hawaii by the way but anyway
they they never gave us a recommendation
to wish at least five of the six didn't
agree so they were almost unanimous a
lot of time they were unanimous
and they always gave the recommendation
to us completely secretly and we could
either ignore it completely or or put it
into effect in some form after
consulting with our cabinet members and
others so it was a very good way to I
say do away with the constant
wrangling or arguments publicly between
me and 20 United States of Japan and so
I in a very brief way maybe briefer than
I just used I wrote that in and
suggested that idea to the president rum
and I said